within minutes of the final whistle
blowing in america now stadium in rio de
janeiro
argentine fans began gathering in the
center of buenos aires
and towns and cities across the country
to celebrate winning a trophy they'd not
captured since 1993
before many of them were born
we are very happy the truth is with
these difficult times we are living
through this has made us very happy we
are going to celebrate with the children
i am happy i'm happy i've been waiting
for this moment for my whole life
it makes me very happy thank you messi
for being argentine
my heart is bursting with happiness
not winning the copper america or the
world cup is simply not good enough for
argentine football fans
who consider their team one of the best
in the world blessed with the best
player in the world
in lionel messi
he's been a beaten finalist several
times and at 34 years old many were
wondering whether he'd ever lift a major
international trophy
now he has with many fans as happy for
him as they are for argentina
it was a difficult tournament after
argentina brazil
both suffering very high infection and
death rates uh with the kobit 19
pandemic
this a moment of distraction of light
relief
from what has been a very difficult time
for people across south america
it was almost a tournament that never
happened at all laid in the midst of the
coronavirus pandemic and political
turmoil
argentina and colombia being forced to
withdraw as co-hosts
just weeks before it started and brazil
offering to host at the last minute
despite the controversy despite the
covert 19 restrictions
the football went ahead and argentina
and linnel messi emerged victorious
these celebrations are likely to
continue for some time to come
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires